down his 14th
irving from three bang kyrie irving from
way downtown
not that time deflected taken by
iguodala off to the races drive past
irving gets inside leia blocked by james
back out to curry open three
[Applause]
iguodala with a good push
and james the second chase down block
of the game
i like what lebron james did a
sensational offensive talent
nearly falls drives now spins back tough
fall away shot it's good
kyrie irving foul too
but he is just on a roll
the balance the handle and the ability
to create just enough separation to get
a clean look
[Music]
[Applause]
james fakes james drives james finishes
and the foul
and a chance for a three-point play to
tie the game
putting them in pick-and-rolls
recognizes the switch
puts his head down and has an
appointment with the rim
clearly contact in the big time finish
by james
a chance for the three-point play
otherwise speaking of stat guys our
statistician dave freed reminds me
it's the clock up
irving on the drive bank shot is good
kyrie irving again
kyrie says that steph curry allow me to
have this dance look at uses the size
the strength
little push off with the shoulders from
about seven years ago my son was playing
high school basketball with a loaded
team
playing in a christmas tournament
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
james against rush leans in trying to
draw the foul got him up
count it and won 40 points for lebron
james
very good individual defense by rush
the last two possessions until he bit on
the shot fake
and james just too strong
well the last time two
[Applause]
irving slides inside tops it right with
him irving bank shot is good and a foul
kyrie irving does it again he's got 33.
[Applause]
just offensive brilliance right here
great defense the fade
the use of the glass
he's now fourth